greetings Gothamites I'm Walter burn AZ
ACK and this is top five yesterday the
newest DC animated movie Batman and
Harley Quinn hit theaters for one night
only so today we're taking a look back
at Batman's best animated films over the
years there had been a lot of great
Batman animated movies with his
popularity at an all-time high the Caped
Crusader's animated outings aren't gonna
be slowing down anytime soon arguably
Batman functions best in cartoon form
there are things you can do in animation
with this character that you obviously
can't do in comics and can't do as well
in live-action form now not every Batman
animated movie has been a winner but
since the early 90s DC always seems to
put their best effort into making these
projects as high-quality as possible
but which of those projects are the
cream of the crop which ones come to
mind immediately when you think of the
Dark Knight himself I compiled the list
similar to this a few years back and
while a lot of my thoughts on these
films remain the same I did have a
change of heart on the ranking of them
this time around these are the top 5
best Batman animated movies number 5
Batman year one this Frank Miller
classic was adapted to the small screen
with detail and care one of the things I
like most about it is that the story
focuses heavily on Jim Gordon Bruce
Wayne returns to Gotham after years away
at the same time Jim Gordon arrives in
his new city throughout the course of
one year mirroring stories portrayed
Bruce becoming the Batman and putting
the city's crime lords on notice while
Gordon battled corruption within the
police department the famous pair are
made aware of each other and slowly
realize they are on an unavoidable
collision course Frank Miller's Batman
year one comic is a well respected work
that helped define the modern
interpretation of Batman and major
elements of his origin the film comes
very close to capturing the tone and
feel of that comic it really showcases
how great of a character pre
Commissioner Gordon is he's a real
badass in this and it's to the stories
benefit that we get to see a lot of
what's happening from his perspective
also with Brian cran
in voicing Gotham's best cop he feels
that much more special it's been years
since I had to take out a green beret
even so he deserves a handicap the
animation and narrations in this movie
are top-notch seeing the desperation of
Batman as he struggles to begin his life
as the Caped Crusader was effective as
he gets more confident we start to see
the Batman we all recognize you can
never escape me nothing harms me but I
know pain I know pain sometimes I share
it with someone like you one thing I
didn't enjoy quite as much was the voice
of Batman and Bruce Wayne here Ben
McKenzie is currently best known for
playing a young Commissioner Gordon on
Fox's Gotham show I feel like if they
got someone better suited for Batman
this film may have been a little higher
on the list regardless it doesn't take
away much from the overall peace the
gritty origin of Batman is told in this
great animated movie based on a
legendary comic number for Batman mask
of the phantasm thank goodness this was
just released on blu-ray it was long
overdue a mysterious figure is killing
some of Gotham's most dangerous
gangsters some believe it to be the
Batman but the truth behind this
phantasm is much more complicated in
addition to this present-day threat we
see the beginning of Batman's presence
in Gotham and discover things weren't
always so grim for the young Bruce Wayne
mask of the phantasm has an interesting
story behind its creation in Batman the
Animated Series writer Paul dinis recent
graphic novel Dark Knight a true Batman
story we get a little peek behind the
scenes of what was happening with one of
the series most prominent writers at the
time of the making of this movie that's
a great read and I'd suggest picking it
up for much much more than just the mask
of the phantasm stuff this film is
filled with amazing images of music and
moments I love how it delves into
Bruce's past and has it sympathize with
him even more it makes him human when we
see that he was so close to having a
great
relatively normal life with a woman he
loved how that all fell apart
logically progresses him to fully
embrace his dark destiny you are now I'm
changing the plan
[Music]
the atmosphere in this film is just
perfect the settings treat our eyeballs
to visual brilliance and are not to be
understated mask of the phantasm is a
beautiful film to look at while the
story and characters raise it to another
level of greatness with Kevin Conroy is
Batman and Mark Hamill as the Joker it
really doesn't get any better also the
addition of the phantasm makes for an
intriguing new character who is as
interesting as she is haunting away from
me you freak
[Music]
there are too many moments to talk about
here but rest assured Batman mask of the
phantasm is still a thrilling watch over
two decades later number three the Dark
Knight Returns part two I loved part 1
but part 2 is clearly superior to me we
get to see the culmination of one of
Batman's greatest stories with tragedy
action and the ultimate face-off
another Frank Miller comic is adapted
into an extraordinary animated movie as
the Joker awakens from his catatonic
state
one last devastating act causes the
final confrontation between Batman and
his oldest foe all this happens before
an old ally arrives and the fight of all
fights takes place finishing the Dark
Knight Returns story called for a big
ending as seen in the book the stuff
with the Joker in this film is very dark
and it had to be the only thing I
dislike about Joker in this movie is the
voice acting it just wasn't enough to
fill out that demented smile it's not a
big complaint but it was strange to me
that they didn't find someone with more
of an intimidating vocal presence of
course a lot of the Batman Superman
fight in this story is used in
live-action form in Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice at least that part of
the movie looked cool and the Dark
Knight Returns this fight delivers on
much more than just the visual thrill of
seeing Batman and Superman slug it out
the characters history with each other
drives the battle and it is so
satisfying to watch in all the years to
come in your most private moments I want
you to remember the one man who beat you
this is one of my all-time favorite
comics and seeing it adapted so well as
a two-part animated film brought me and
a ton of fans a whole lot of joy if you
haven't already go check out the Dark
Knight Returns parts 1 & 2 they're both
great number 2 Batman Beyond return of
the Joker this was a great setup for a
story in the Batman Beyond Canon and it
was executed to perfection the Joker is
back to lead the gang he inspired and
tear down the world of anyone close to
the original Batman
now elderly Bruce Wayne the mystery
surrounding his sudden return brings to
light dark details about his supposed
death and how Batman's allies were
affected with Terry McGinnis now filling
out the cowl he must contend with
Batman's greatest foe without the
experience his predecessor had in
dealing with the Clown Prince of Crime
Batman Beyond was a great TV show in
line with Bruce Tim's Batman the
Animated Series Superman the animated
series and Justice League I can say
without a doubt that this is the best
story told in that futuristic Batman
Beyond world this film is the perfect
bridge between the original animated
series and Batman Beyond there are
detailed flashback sequences that show
how the Joker met his fate as we see the
old Batman team together one more time
these scenes are some of the best Bruce
Timm and company have ever put together
and they are twisted
behind all the sturm and batter eggs
you're just a little boy in the play
suit crying for mommy and daddy it would
be funny if it weren't so pathetic no
what the heck laughs anyway hearing Mark
Hamill and Kevin Conroy together is
always something to be excited about add
that to Bruce now being in his late 70s
or 80s while the Joker has been away for
so long and you have something very
unique Joker's back in town
oh no your old eyes do not deceive you
brucey after all
don't be better than you Wilfred L is
great as Terry and also adds a different
dimension to his verbal spats with the
Joker this new Batman isn't Bruce Wayne
so the different dynamic that is created
shows us a side of the Joker we rarely
if ever saw in any other Hamill voiced
interpretation you make me laugh but
only because I think you're kind of
pathetic
[Laughter]
Bruce and Terry's relationship also
grows in this film Bruce doesn't want to
put another one of his proteges up
against the Joker after what happened to
Tim Drake so there's a tension created
between teacher and student it's what I
want Bruce stupid kid you don't know
what you want none of you ever did
[Music]
and this scene is just terrified
if you want to see how the Batman
animated series version of the Joker bit
the dust and why Batman Beyond is so
great this one's for you even if you've
never seen the Batman Beyond show this
will get any Batman fan interested in
The Adventures of old Bruce Wayne and
young Terry McGinnis
[Music]
and the number one best Batman animated
movie is Batman under the Red Hood under
the Red Hood is a nearly perfect Batman
movie a new vigilante is controlling the
crime game in Gotham City this
mysterious new agent goes by the Red
Hood and when Batman Begins dealing with
this foe cowl to helmet he finds out
that Red Hood
isn't just another criminal he connects
the Batman's past and ways thought
impossible this movie was done so well I
would have loved to seat in theaters in
just about 70 minutes under the Red Hood
introduces Jason Todd the second Robin
has us invested in his story and reveals
new reasons why the Joker is such an
important part of Batman's life all
grown up and to be a big bully pills
based on the comic book storyline by
Judd Winick with a few pages sneaked in
from the famous death in the family arc
this movie tells a great story with
perfect pacing Winnick actually pitched
the film to Warner Brothers animation
and wrote it himself
the result is something that was
obviously well thought out Jason Todd
was the second Robin after Dick Grayson
he was always a hothead that didn't
listen to Batman all the time and got
angrier as he got older
Bruce's attempt to save this young boy
ultimately became his demise when the
Joker viciously beat him and left him to
die in a fiery explosion it was Batman's
greatest defeat and the one that weighs
heaviest on his heart that emotional
core drives the film to Heights still
unequaled in any Batman animated movie
in my opinion then I got him killed
my partner my soldier my fault
I own that
I'll carry that like everything else
another nice little detail is that it's
just really cool to see black masks on
screen he's definitely a lesser-known
Batman villain so getting to see him in
this movie was both awesome and
hilarious you're an idiot
everything about Jason Bruce and Joker's
intertwined destinies culminate in the
climax and is pulled off without a hitch
all I've ever wanted to do is kill him a
day doesn't go by when I don't think
about subjecting him to every horrendous
torture he's dealt out to others and
then end him oh so you do think about me
the animation is great the tone is great
it has a lot of heart Bruce Greenwood as
Batman is fantastic John DiMaggio as the
Joker is something different and in the
best way there are quiet character
moments and great action sequences
seamlessly woven into each other it's
just incredible all around I can't
recommend Batman under the Red Hood
enough it's a victory for animation and
shows how powerful Batman is in that
medium it came out in 2010 and has yet
to be topped watch this movie that's all
I can say
there you have it does Batman in Harley
Quinn continue the legacy of Batman's
animated greatness if you saw it tell me
what you thought of it and if it
deserves to be included in your personal
top 5 best cartoon films about the
world's greatest detective what's your
favorite Batman animated movie leave a
comment and let me know for more content
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter like my
new Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow me on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week for a brand new episode
of top 5
[Music]
you